when it comes to serial child killer
Albert fish the adjectives to describe
as inhumanity hardly seems strong enough
to prove a perverted deviant degenerate
he was all of that but he was much more
the crimes he committed fill the heart
with rage while the taunting letters he
sent the victims families make you
wonder how a human being could possibly
be so cruel in this week's by graphics
we venture into the sordid life of Alba
fish and fair warning this episode it
ain't pretty
[Music]
Hamilton Howard Albert fish was born on
May the 19th 1870 in Washington DC
his father Randall was 75 years old when
he was born being 43 years older than
his mother Ellen the old man died when
Albert was 5 years old and the children
they were placed into an orphanage at
the orphanage Albert sang in the choir
he was also subjected to merciless
beatings by other boys as well as even
staff members the physical pain of the
beatings and the whippings he came to
realize gave him a sort of sexual
pleasure he would get erections midway
through a beating which would bring
ridicule and further torment from the
older boys Albert spent four years at
the orphanage when he was nine his
mother secured a job and took her
children back two years later Albert
began a relationship with a telegraph
boy who introduced him to a range of
depraved practices including drinking
urine and eating feces
he also took to hanging out a local
bathing room so that he could watch
young boys getting undressed but around
the age of 11 Albert fell from a cherry
tree and suffered a serious concussion
this would result in constant headaches
dizzy spells and a pronounced stutter
in 1890 he moved to New York City with
his mother he would later tell the
police that he became a male prostitute
at this time but this has never been
substantiated he began working as a
painter and a paperhanger throughout the
1890s according to his later testimony
he regularly molested young children
preferring those who were under the age
of six he also enjoyed writing obscene
letters to women who had placed personal
ads in the newspapers in 1898 Albert's
mother arranged for him to marry a 19
year old girl by the name of Anna Marie
Hoffman they would go on to have six
children at the same time he maintained
sexual relationships with a string of
male lovers one of them took him to a
waxworks Museum during which time now
that became fascinated by a model of a
dissected human penis it was this
experience that developed in him a
fascination with genital mutilation and
castration for the rest of his life he
would insert needles into his scrotum
and penis in order to achieve sexual
satisfaction
in 1903 fish was arrested for
embezzlement and sentence to Sing Sing
prison during his incarceration he
regularly had sex with other men after
his release his children recalled that
his behavior became increasingly bizarre
he would regularly hear voices and he
claimed that he was receiving messages
from the Apostle John on one occasion
his oldest son Albert jr. saw him
standing on a hillside with his arms
outstretched he was screaming I am
Christ he was convinced that he was
being directed by God to castrate little
boys psychiatrists would later diagnose
him with a condition known as religious
mania the children would also recall
seeing their father flagellating himself
on the back with a nail-studded paddle
in 1910 fish began a sexual relationship
with a 19 year old intellectually
disabled man by the name of Thomas Caden
fish was working away from home in
Wilmington Delaware
he brought Kent back to his room and the
two engaged in sadomasochistic sexual
acts over a period of days these acts
became more and more like torture with
fish inflicting all of the pain he took
get into an old farmhouse with the
intention of killing the boy and
dissecting his body in the end he merely
cut off half of Kevin's penis before
leaving him to his own fate in 1917
Fisher's wife left him for another man
Albert was left with six children to
raise on his own according to fish Anna
took virtually all of the possessions
that the family owned it was from this
point that his paranoia took on new
dimensions his children once found him
wrapped up in a carpet since he would
encourage them to hit him on the bare
buttocks with his nail-studded paddle
however none of the children ever claims
that their father physically abused them
it was around this time that Al began
experimenting with cannibalism
he started by eating raw meat which he
would also serve to the children and
then this escalated to human flesh
in 1919 Phish intensified his criminal
activities abducting abusing and
murdering young boys in and around the
Washington DC area his typical victim
would be black or intellectually
impaired as he believed that the police
would be less inclined to pursue the
disappearance of these children he
developed the skill of luring children
away by offering them gifts and
appearing to be exceedingly kind and
flattering towards them in July 1924
fish came across a young girl who was
playing alone on her parents Staten
Island farm he had convinced the girl to
go off with him to pick rhubarb when the
mother arrived and scared him off still
his obsession with the eight-year-old
girl forced him to return and he tried
to sleep in the barn once again he was
discovered this time by the father and
he was once again chased away another
botched abduction occurred when he
invited two young boys to his apartment
for lunch while he was preparing the
food the boys waited in his bedroom
they began play wrestling on the bed and
then they fell onto the floor there they
saw under the bed fish's self-described
instruments of hell a meat cleaver a
hacksaw and a knife frightened out of
their wit's the two boys took to their
heels running past fish and right out of
the apartment fish's modus operandi of
snatching the unimportance in the UNMISS
twas thrown into chaos when he
unwittingly abducted and murdered
Francis McDonald the son of a Staten
Island police officer the eight-year-old
was playing ball on the street with four
friends when fish who had been hanging
around for hours called the boy over
when his friends turned to see where
Francis was both here in the stranger
had gone
when Francis failed to return home his
father sent out after him after scouring
the neighborhood and questioning the
other boys he kept hearing about the
gray-haired man who had been hanging
around then he telegraphed police
headquarters the next day a massive
search was underway throughout Staten
Island's eventually though the body of
Francis McDonald was found by three Boy
Scouts under a pile of branches and
leaves on a rural property all of the
clothing below the child's waist had
been pulled from his body it was
apparent that he had been viciously
sexually assaulted fish had finished him
off by strangling Francis with his own
suspenders which were wound so tightly
that they appeared to be a part of his
flesh within minutes more than 50 police
officers were surround
the body the next day the case was given
the highest priority with 250 officers
assigned to it the boy's father Arthur
McDonald was transferred from Manhattan
precinct to Staten Island so that he
could personally work on his son's case
the autopsy on Francis body revealed
that he had been eating raisins just
prior to his death the police concluded
that this must have been the lure that
the killer used to pull the boy away the
terrible condition of the body caused
the coroner to conclude that the
attacker could not have been an elderly
man of course that degree of physical
damage he must have been in this prime
hysteria swept through the state and
daily reports came in of sightings of
the gray man in the weeks following the
discovery of the child's body dozens of
men were questioned with several being
arrested but later released hopes for an
early resolutions the case vanished as
the leads just dried up with public
interest in the case fading the dead
boy's mother made a desperate plea to
the public help us catch the monster who
killed our boy help us find the gray man
on May the 25th 1928 18 year-old Edward
Byrd placed a one-line classified
advertisement in the New York world
newspaper in an attempt to find
employment three days later an elderly
man knocked on the front door of the
Byrd apartment on 15th Street in
Manhattan he said his name was Frank
Howard and he was replying to the
situation's wanted ad in the paper
Edward buds mother invited him in and
sent his younger sister Beatrice to
fetch a brother from next door
Edward soon turned up with his friend
William toe Howard offered both boys
jobs on his farm in Farmingdale Long
Island he then told them that he would
return on Saturday and drive the boys to
the farm the following Saturday the boys
waited excitedly with their bags packed
but mr. Howard he never turned up in
stairs a telegraph was delivered which
told the boys that Howard had been
delayed and would come for the boys the
next day he turns up in the early
afternoon on Sunday just as the family
had returned from church he was invited
to stay for lunch
it was while sitting at the food table
that mr. Howard got his first view of
grace but the pretty a year old was
dressed in her best Sunday clothes
the old man was immediately smitten
beckoning grace over to him she looked
to her mother who nodded her assent mr.
Howard told grace how pretty she was he
then asked if she was a good counter
when she nodded he pulls from his
pockets the biggest one of money that
anyone in the room had ever seen he laid
the cash and the coins on the table and
asked graced counter firm grace counted
out ninety-two dollars and fifty cents
at the conclusion of which mr. Howard
rewarded her with a fifty cent piece and
told her to go and buy some candy for
her sister again the mother nodded her
approval and the little girl left the
room happy it was then that the old man
informed the buds that there had been a
slight change of plan
he had to attend his young nieces
birthday party that afternoon but he
would return for the boys that evening
then just as he was leaving he turned to
mr. Barden said that he just had a
thought would they allow him to take
young grace to the birthday party he
said it was going to be good fun there
was going to be lots of food and games
and plenty of children her age and of
course he would have her back by nine
o'clock
mrs. bud was hesitant they didn't even
know this man but he did seem
exceedingly kind and he clearly loved
children before she could answer husband
had made up a mind for her saying that
the girl never got out
it would be good for her to have some
fun for a change mrs. Budd wanted to
know where the party was going to be how
it answered that it was at his sister's
place at 130 7th and Columbus Avenue the
buds didn't realize that Columbus Street
ends at a hundred and tenth Street
so the address did not exist and so it
was the young grace bud was dressed up
in a spring coat and gray hat with blue
streamers and headed off up the street
with the gray man
mrs. bird stood at the door and watched
them disappear around the corner it was
the last time that she ever saw her
daughter the buds waited with growing
alarm for mr. Howard to return with
grace by Monday morning mrs. bud was
hysterical with worry Edward was rushed
off to the nearest police station to
report that the girl was missing a short
time later four detectives arrived at
the bird home to question the family
about kidnapping it was big news all
over the country the case was unique in
that the whole bird family had got in a
long and detailed look at the so called
mr. Howard thousands of Flyers were
printed with a detailed description
accompanied by a photo of grace
these were distributed throughout the US
as well as Canada as expected there were
a rash of false sightings and leads that
went nowhere but then a solid lead
finally emerged the telegraph office
where Howard had send the Telegraph to
the buds from was identified an
intensive search of that area then found
another clue a food basket that Howard
had left at the buds house was
identified and the man who had sold it
to Howard was tracked down from this it
was deduced that the kidnapper was a
resident of East Harlem but from there
the trail that went cold despite a raft
of letters and confessions coming in
nothing panned out
then in September 1930 there was a break
in the case police arrested a 66 year
old by the name of Charles Edward Pope
Pope was held in custody for three and a
half months and then put on trial Oh
need to be found in not guilty in
November 1934 the still grieving parents
of grace Byrd received an excruciating
ly gruesome letter which police later
confirmed was from Albert Fish it read
in part I grabs her and she said she
would tell her mama first I stripped her
naked how she did kick bite and scratch
I choked her to death then cut her in
small pieces so I could take my meat to
my rooms cook and eat it how sweet and
tender
little-ass was roasted in the oven it
took me nine days to
our entire body
[Music]
the police were able to compare the
handwriting in the letter to the
telegraph notes that they had recovered
years before it was immediately obvious
that they were written by the same
person but it wasn't the letter itself
that finally brought Albert fish down
it was the envelope in which it was
contained printed on the back of the
envelope flap where the initials NY PCB
a police were able to track it down to
the New York private chauffeurs
benevolent association they found out
that a janitor at the Association had
taken a bunch of envelopes home to his
rooming house at 622 Lexington Avenue
detectives descended on the
boardinghouse but were frustrated that
no one there recognized the description
of mr. Howard but then the janitor
remembered that when he had taken the
envelopes yet not yet moved to Lexington
Avenue
he still had been living at East 52nd
Street when a detective showed the
landlady the description of mr. Howard
she immediately recognized him as the
elderly man who had moved in when the
janitor had left the officer asked to
see the man's signature in the register
pulling out the letter that had been
sent to mrs. Budd he could see that the
signature was written by the same person
who wrote the disgusting letter the man
had signed his name as Albert H fish the
detective discovered from the landlady
that Albert fish who had moved out a few
days earlier received regular support
checks from his son on several occasions
he had asked the landlady to cash the
checks on his behalf it just so happens
that the check was due any day and fish
had said that he would return for it the
police now set up a 24-hour surveillance
of the boardinghouse yet after three
weeks
there was still no sign of fish and the
surveillance was reluctantly called off
then on December the 4th the landlady of
the rooming house phones the police to
inform them that fish had just come in
and inquired about his check in fact she
was still there the landlady was told to
stall him she ushered him into a room
and gave him a cup of tea minutes later
a detective walked into the room and
looking at the frail old man on the
couch said Albert fish fish was
momentarily taken aback but then he
reached into his vest pocket and pulled
out a razor blade and held it out
threatening Lee the detective quickly
closed in and grabbed the old man's
wrists and twisted the blade fell to the
floor and the pathetic killer slumped
back down on the couch looking down at
the man had been hunting for years the
detective simply said
I've got you now Albert fish went on
trial for the murder of grace Bart on
March the 11th 1935 then I performed he
had managed to extract a chicken bone
from the soupy had been served sharpen
it to a point and proceeded to
repeatedly stabbed himself with it when
a guard heard him moaning he rushed in
and managed to take the makeshift weapon
away from him
it was reported as a suicide attempt but
it was simply a means of satisfying his
deranged sexual desires throughout the
ten day trial fish maintains an
indifferent attitude
he sat humped in his chair often with
his eyes closed and appeared to show
absolutely no interest in what was going
on one reporter described him as
resembling a corpse in securely props in
a chair the defense readily admitted
that fish committed the crime it was
their contention however that he was
legally insane at the time of the
killing and that he remains that way as
he sat in front of them
the prosecution on the other hand set
out to prove the opposite that he was
saying that he knew the wrongness of
what he was doing and therefore he must
answer for his actions the prosecution
called a series of psychiatrists as
witnesses each of whom stated that the
defendant was sane though suffering from
a whole host of psychotic conditions in
the end the prosecution did persuade the
jury that fish was sane they found him
guilty of murder in the first degree the
sentence was execution in the electric
chair at Sing Sing prison one of the
jurors later revealed that most of the
jurors actually felt that fish was
insane but they felt more strongly that
he was deserving of the electric chair
Albert fish's last day on earth was
January the 16th 1936 he was escorted
into the execution chamber at 11:06 p.m.
he clasped his hands together in prayer
as he was lowered into the chair and
strapped in the leather cap was fitted
and electrodes were attached to his skin
as the current surged through his body
Alba fish's body jolted backward and
veins in his neck bulged and his fists
involuntarily clenched then his body
went limp the monster it was no more so
I'm absolutely not going to ask if you
enjoyed that video but I do hope you
found it interesting maybe there
Luminator a little darker period of
history for you if you did like it
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe
we've got brand new videos twice a week
on this channel
and as always thank you for watching
you
[Music]